en la ciudad de monterrey un hombre
regala tatuajes a quienes hayan vencido
al cob y 19 sobrevivientes se escribe
sobre sus pieles y es que aunque en
méxico más de 400 mil personas han
vencido al virus casi 65 mil han muerto
a causa de la enfermedad el país tiene
hoy la mayor tasa de letalidad en todo
el mundo según el registro de la
universidad johns hopkins
casi 11 fallecidos por cada 100 personas
contagiadas muy por encima de eeuu y
brasil que juntos suman casi 10 millones
de casos positivos el joven 19 llegó por
primera vez a méxico el 28 de febrero y
hoy seis meses después es el octavo país
más afectado del mundo y el cuarto en
américa latina' al inicio del brote su
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
dejó claro su escepticismo frente al
impacto del virus ignorando el
distanciamiento social y alentando a las
aglomeraciones
y no dejen
y salir todavía estamos en la primera
fase ya nosotros yo les voy a decir
cuando no salga su actitud se reflejó en
la falta de pruebas hoy méxico es
señalado como el país de la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico que menos pruebas realiza a su
población el mismo gobierno llegó a
reconocer que el recuento oficial no
reflejaba la cifra real de contagios
habló también se negaba a la aplicación
de medidas drásticas como el cierre de
aeropuertos y negocios no esenciales
pero los casos empezaron a dispararse
casi a finales de abril por lo que no
tuvo más remedio que seguir los pasos de
sus países vecinos pero estas medidas no
duraron mucho tiempo el primero de junio
ya habían salido de una cuarentena que
sólo duró dos meses tras la cual cada
región implementa medidas de acuerdo a
un semáforo epidemiológico es decir mide
las cantidades de casos en la zona para
decidir que puede estar abierto
lópez obrador reconoció que la
emergencia generada por la enfermedad ha
provocado la crisis económica más
profunda
en un siglo